new in theaters this weekend axel the
happy time murders and searching what
will you see this is your weekend ticket
this week's top ticket is great for the
entire family
axel is an action-adventure film the
story follows a teenage boy named Miles
who discovers and saves a super advanced
military great robotic dog and you
guessed it they become best friends
let's go bad news for miles the dog also
called axel short for attack exploration
logistics is a top-secret military
project with the help of miles new crush
Sara they must protect each other and
avoid getting caught at all costs and
also maybe find a little time to learn
how to dance this one is for you if
you're looking for a fun family movie to
watch this weekend canine companionship
real or robotic holds a soft spot in
your heart or you work on top-secret
military projects but can't tell anyone
about it and you mean an outlet for the
frustration this causes looking for some
rotten cotton I'm a woman that's okay
good time for you if you're looking for
a movie that is definitely probably not
for the entire family
check out the happy timers don't be
fooled by the fact that there are
puppets in this movie these are not your
typical puppets
hey you don't come at me like that but
50 cents gopher will give you a fealty a
fealty no in a world where puppets live
alongside humans private investigator
Phil a puppet must team up with
detective Connie Edwards a human to stop
a serial killer from continuing a string
of puppet murders the rarely seen seedy
underbelly of the puppet world is full
of foul-mouthed drug using puppets with
questionable moral compasses filthy
puppets Plus Melissa McCarthy are sure
to deliver on the copy of this dark
crime drama this
for you if you like rhonchi puppet humor
like Team America world police Melissa
McCarthy comedies make you laugh out
loud or you want to see a movie with
Stanley from the office 9-1-1 what's
your emergency I'm calling to report a
missing person okay who is this
regarding my daughter and finally if
you're searching for a movie about
searching then your search is over
searching is for you starring John Cho
and Debra Messing and shot entirely from
the POV of electronic devices this indie
thriller follows the plight of a father
looking for his missing 16 year old
daughter taking matters into his own
hands he investigates through her web
history and interviews with her
supposedly closest friends since its
world premiere at the 2018 Sundance Film
Festival distribution rights were
purchased by Sony Pictures worldwide
acquisitions this movie is for you if
you like movies with that indie
found-footage vibe like unfriended or
Paranormal Activity or if you're into
movies where parents take matters into
their own hands and will do anything for
their kids that is your weekend ticket
what will you see and check back next
week for a sci-fi action movie tin
[Music]
you